And I want to welcome you to a topic that I wanted to do for a very long time. It's about all the things that Jung talked about when he talked about the body. Because interestingly enough, he was a psychologist. He dealt with the psyche, with the mind of people. But at the same time, he talks really a lot about the body.
And this is one of the topics that you normally don't find When you look up things about Jung, you very often find these archetypes, dreams, individuation, shadow, all those things. There's like these concepts that are known, at least by name, by many, a lot of people.
And through my exploration into the works of Jung, I encounter certain concepts where I thought, oh, this is really interesting and nobody is talking about that. So what I've been doing for the last 2 years was building a kind of introductory course where I talk about these topics of archetypes, dreams, individuation, or synchronicity.
And now I want to go into really specific, very little known topics of Jung to explore what, what they are. And he's great with ideas. He's great with hypotheses, how human beings work, how interactions work, how the psyche works, or in this case, even the body. And yeah, set that then into a bigger context.
And the first thing that one might notice when you read Jung is that he very often uses analogies of the body and compares the psyche to the body. As example, he says, if you look, for example, in your family tree and in your relatives that you have that are currently living or even dead, when you have pictures.
You will find that you are very similar looking to them, but it's like a mixture that you have the nose from that relative, the ears from the other relatives, your height from another relative, but there's some kind of building blocks in your appearance that also come up in your relatives.
And he says the exact same thing is happening with the psyche, like how you are structured internally. Is also similar how your immediate relatives or your family are structured internally. It's not only a mix of match of your physical appearance, but also of your psychology coming up.
So he really says that, that they're kind of family spirits or family psychology that are coming together in a child, mostly through the, through the parents, through the mother and the father that he's saying, like, it's the child is not the child of the parent. Of the mother and the father, but rather of the whole family. So this is why children can be so different.
And he uses just the analogy of the body because it's very graspable. Like the body for us as an example or an analogy works way better than the psyche because the psyche, it's dark, it's muddy. It's even hard to perceive in many cases. This is why we did not have psychology for a very, very long time in human history and science and recalling.
But rather this recent phenomena of describing the psyche and psychology. And he tries to make it very graspable with a lot of examples.
And this is how, for example, this works, that he says not only like the body parts or the psychological building blocks that you have are similar to the body, but also similar to the body, there are parts of the psyche that can never be conscious.
He says consciousness is the things that you know, you can understand, and that you can also relate, let's say, to yourself. So everything that you know, that you are, that you have experienced, this is connected to the I in German, das Ich, or in English, ego.
But he says that there's some things that can never really be integrated, understood, be known in the psyche. Similar As a body, you, you have a body, you live in a body, but at the same time, what you actually experience from the body is very, very little because many things are automatic, like your whole digestion, your heart, your breathing.
This is all unconscious automatic behavior that happens in the background without you thinking about it. This is a good thing. If you would have to think about our heart beating and keeping it on via conscious effort, I guess everybody would have been dying. Already a long time ago. And he says the same thing as with the psyche and with the unconscious.
They're just processes happening in the background where you can feel the effects when they're not working, but normally not. They're just always there in the background working. And this is how he describes instincts or archetypes or complexes. These are just organisms that are inside your psyche acting.
With an agenda, a worldview, goal, actions, similar as you have in your body a lot of self-sufficient parts, like your liver does its own thing, or even your digestive system has a lot of bacteria. Again, a tremendous amount of human body weight is just bacteria. They have their own thing.
They do their own automatic processes and have their own worldview. And agendas separated from what we want. And like that also, as a body grows and changes over time, the psyche changes over time.
So we start as a small child, we grow up, we are not so, let's say, sophisticated in what we do, walking, grasping things, talking, and we grow bigger and stronger with time. And at a certain point it shifts and the body becomes weaker, more frail, and at a certain point it dies. And he says that also about the psyche, that psychological needs change.
And we know this and have this conception, for example, for puberty. We can say, oh yeah, a child is very different than a teenager and it's very different from an adult. But what Jung also talked about a lot was that our psychological needs change, and it does not stop just because we hit 18 and are through puberty.
But there's also things later on, like beyond the age of 40, that just our psychological needs change. And this is how we have to restructure our life. And this again is easier to explain with the body because it's more visible, it's more graspable.
And One part that he very uses very, very often is to say when we have a depression or, well, he would call it neurosis or complex, he would compare it to, okay, how does the body react to a foreign agent like a virus?
When you have a virus, you get a fever, but the fever is not from the virus. The fever is the reaction of the body to kill the virus. And he says it's the same thing for neurosis, that this is a healing mechanism to make you aware of certain things, to push your awareness in a certain direction. This is also something that Freud said.
This depression, this turning inward is shining the spotlight on specific problems that you have, but you're in your normal life not aware of, but you should be aware of. So Your body reacts or your psyche reacts. So a lot of comparisons and a lot of analogies that work for Jung.
And this doesn't mean that psyche and body act the exact same way, but there's huge overlaps and huge similarities. Both have their own domain, but they're way closer than, than we think.
And this is something that Jung stresses really a lot that you cannot only focus on the psyche and you cannot only focus on the body. When you have a solution, you have to take the whole person into account. And I have a great quote here.
The body is merely a visibility of the soul, the psyche, and the soul is a psychological experience of the body. So it is really one and the same thing. Therefore, a good truth must be true for the whole system, not only half of it.
And he would use very often the body to look into the psyche because of those connections, because they're not completely separated things that are not related to each other. That is, yeah, it's a ghost in a machine, the psyche, but rather it's intertwined and intertangled. Body and soul are one thing. We do not suffer in just one isolated corner of the whole.
If the part suffers, the whole suffers. And this is something very interesting, how he treated patients. So Jung was a therapist and he worked his whole life as a therapist and had patients. And he would look in all aspects of the life of the patient. So he would not only take an isolated human being, but but rather say, okay, what relations do you have?
How are you integrated in your family and to other groups and to society? What is your history, your past? But he would also take a look at the body and draw comparisons there that bodily symptoms are a sign of psychological trouble.
And I have another quote: So such suspended ideas can express themselves easily in the body. And certain skin troubles, for instance, or superficial nervous troubles, anesthesia perhaps. Also very frequently troubles of the stomach and intestines, fits of diarrhea or constipation.
People who do not want to give something away produce an extraordinary constipation. There are very funny things like that, quite comical, so obvious that one doesn't believe it. But we are quite disinclined to believe the obvious things. We always think that the truth must be very complicated, very subtle. If one says something quite simple, everybody thinks it's not true.
So to draw this comparison between, okay, something, somebody does not want to give something away, that's why they have constipation, or somebody cannot swallow a truth, right? Cannot digest it, is that they have problems with swallowing. And he comes from a psychoanalytic school of thought.
He worked a long time with Freud and was very intertwined with the psychological school in, in the beginning when it came up around 1900. And this was around the time when psychology came up and also the understanding of human troubles changed.
So in the past, when somebody had psychological problems, what we would call psychological problems today, when they would act crazy, weird, strange, the go-to theory was a materialistic one to say they have brain damage. So something in the machine is broken. This is why the, the ghost in the machine is not working.
And he did not believe in that because He worked also as a doctor in, in a, in a clinic, and he would observe the autopsies and see that people with schizophrenia, what back then was not known as schizophrenia or psychosis, had perfectly normal looking brains. They were not really damaged in any visible way.
So there already his thought processes started to say, okay, there's, there's troubles. That not purely bodily, but psychological.
And this is what Freud proved with his talking cure, that you can talk with people through their problems, that you, on a psychological, cognitive intellectual level, can solve their problems, that even their bodily symptoms go away. So there is an interaction between those, but it's not only one way.
It's not only there's something wrong in the body, this is something then wrong in the mind, but rather it's something that is wrong in, in the mind that causes bodily problems. And he noticed that, that the bodily problems of patients would disappear when their psychological problems were treated correctly and were solved.
So This interplay between the mind and the body and looking at it. I have another quote for it. When the field of consciousness is limited, the body plays a great role. People who are enamored with themselves are extremely conscious of their bodies.
They attach tremendous importance to how they have eaten, slept, digested, or what impression they have made on others. They tend to connect their complexes with the body. Inner conflicts appear to them in the form of physical illness.
And this is one of the complications that Jung brings up again and again with the psyche, that psychological problems are not immediately obvious as such, but they are never really gone. He sees the psyche as an energetic system, and this energy needs to go somewhere.
So if it's not taken care of in the psyche, then it comes up as a problem, for example, in the digestive system. But even to the degree to saying, okay, everything you're not dealing with, but you should, is happening around you in certain situations. And he uses this example often in complexes.
Complexes are these small auto— autonomous forces in the psyche that interfere with conscious goals. This very not well-known example of the Freudian slip. Where you give away a secret, something you do not want to tell by misspeaking. He says this is a complex.
This is something acting through the body and producing a certain result that you did not intend.
And similar complexes create accidents that you are suddenly clumsy in an important situation, that you hit yourself or have an accident and get hurt basically just to draw your attention to certain problems that you have not dealt with.
So for Jung, like always, everything is connected, and through the weirdest ways, consciousness must deal with it. Like, you as a person have to contend with the fact that maybe the things that are happening to you are because you have not dealt with something, even if they look not really connected. But then the job of consciousness to find this connection.
And in the worst case, of course, this can result in a complete disassociation with the body that people, for example, believe that they do not have a shadow anymore, like shadow on the ground, or that they have no weight anymore. And he says that a lot about intuitive people. And I did an event one month ago about intuition. I can highly recommend it.
And I want to use a quote from there again. One sees that, for instance, with very intuitive people. They are always tempted to live beyond themselves because they know so many possibilities that they can almost live in them as though they could live like that, disregarding the actual possibility, the actual facts.
So the typical disease of intuitive people affects the abdomen because that corresponds with the earth. If you neglect the earth, you neglect the abdomen, and you may get ulcers in the stomach, for instance. The body always takes its revenge when disregarded. So a little bit like, let's say you have an apartment, you have a pet dog.
If you do not take care of the pet dog, it will turn to a very unfriendly dog very quickly. If it doesn't get food, if it does not get out, if it's not played with, it starts acting up. Similar as the body acts up.
As its own systems, not, not necessarily as an extension of the psyche, but as a part, as a partner, something you cannot get really rid of, but you have to contend with it and find out how to work with it.
And this connection that Jung sees between the psyche and the body, the psychological model for Jung is If you think in layers, like in the very top layer on the surface where the light is and what is visible is your consciousness.
And this is also your most individual part because it's the sum of all your experiences and of your personality and everything that happened to you and you can do and you know and so on. It does not get more individual than that, especially when you think about Dreams and Jung, the only person in the world and of all human history that experience your dreams.
There's nothing more subjective or more personal. And below that, for Jung, comes the personal unconscious. Those are the things that are in the dark that you do not want to deal with, or you don't know yet how to deal with. As I said, you develop as a child in your body, but also in your mind.
So you're not your whole personality when you start out and I think everybody would agree when you're a child, you're not you yet, but you're on the way there and you will develop over time through teenage years and adult years and become more and more yourself and more your full potential and personality. And this normally is in the personal unconscious.
So everything that you could be and could know and could do, but cannot do quite yet, either because you have not learned or you have push it aside because, for example, you're very extroverted but grew up in an introverted environment in your childhood home. And those past things are pushed down and repressed, or like trauma or strange experiences.
And you have below that, so this is like the, the personal thing, this is still related to you, but You're more similar in your personal unconscious to other people and where also the shadow is than in your consciousness. And below that, there's something that also not a lot of people know, becomes the family structure, the family psychology.
So things you share with your immediate relatives. Below that, then comes your culture. Below that comes the collective unconscious. And the collective unconscious is basically everything you share psychology-wise with every human being that ever existed and will ever exist. So that's very impersonal. This is where the archetypes are.
And if you go even lower there, then you come to the point, okay, it's not even human beings anymore. It's animals. Like we have instincts that you find in other animals and certain patterns of behavior that you have also, like let's say mammals and then come reptiles and then come even insects and maybe even plants.
And of course, if you go lower and lower, lower, at a certain point you hit the body. And in the body, you're not very individual or personal in the sense of like everything has kind of a body and your body parts, your blood cells, your bones, and so on. This is not very individual.
And if you go even lower, then you come to chemistry and even lower, then it's just physics and quantum dots or whatever. So there's not a clear line to draw, like, okay, where does the mind stop and where the body starts? Because it's all intertwined, it's all intermingled.
And there's something that Dawkins also said, like, if you would, as an alien species, take a duck, you could find out so much about the Earth, about the atmosphere, the physical laws, just by looking at the duck, because the duck is is adapted to the environment that it's living in.
Similar as human beings, similar as our psychology is adapted to a certain reality, which is always with us. And through this body, we're in a pretty special situation because the body binds us to the here and now.
There's not really a way to escape the here and now. Maybe in your mind and maybe in your fantasy, but the body is always there where it is. And I have a great, great quote for that. You cannot be conscious of many things simply because you are not where they are.
I am not conscious of what is happening in the library, for instance, and I cannot hear what somebody says in the library because my ears are here and not there. If I could do without my body, then my ears might be anywhere in New York or in Stockholm. I could hear and see all things. God knows what. But as a matter of fact, there is a body and the body is in time and space.
If it were not, there would not be that restriction of consciousness. Also, if there are no restrictions, there would be no consciousness. For if you are conscious of a million things, as it seems to you, you are conscious of nothing. Your consciousness is then exceedingly blurred, and the distinction, the real essence of consciousness is exclusiveness.
You must be able to exclude many things in order to absolutely be conscious. So the restriction is the very being, the very character of consciousness. And the reason for that distinctiveness, that particular capacity of acuteness of consciousness, is the body, which restricts you to a certain place. At a certain time, in a certain, yeah, moment in time.
And this is the interesting thing because he says that in general about consciousness, that in regards to be conscious, you have to restrict everything else. For example, when you drive a car, you should try to get rid of anything else and concentrate on the road. Otherwise accidents happen and you might die, and other people also.
So, but the body forms a conscious function for that, to have you in this moment in time and being only aware of many limited things.
So some people of you might have heard of it, that there are millions of impressions coming raining down on us every second, but consciously aware we are only of very limited amount and we can only deal with certain things. So you have For example, in the brain, there's this working memory and you can hold something like 5 unrelated facts at a time.
So some people can 6, 7, or 8. It's not like there's some people who can hold millions. It's always, there's a bottleneck and the bottleneck is the body. So things you can perceive, but at the same time, it's necessary for consciousness to develop, to do it step by step, to be only conscious of one thing and then the next thing and then the next thing and then the next thing.
Because only then you can create a complex psychology by building it brick for brick, but every brick in a very decisive way. So moving further with the body and what does it mean that you have a body or things have a body? The interplay for the psyche and the body goes further, and this has to do with libido.
This is a term known from psychoanalysis, from Freud, very much connected to sexuality with Freud, or let's say a survival instinct, because he was not so clear about his definitions and a lot of things fell under sexuality for him. For example, the first coming up of sexuality is when the infant sucks the breast of the mother. For him, that's a sexual act.
And then sexuality goes away until people hit puberty, and then they're interested with like the genitals and so on. So very broad understanding of sexuality from Freud. But for Jung, libido means just force that does something. It's creating something. For example, let's take money.
He said money is a fine symbolization for libido because money can make things happen. Transforms from different forms. Like your work, your labor, it's generated into money, and with that money you can buy a trip or a car or computer or anything. You transform it into a different thing, but the interchangeable medium is money.
And for him, that's libido, and libido turns into certain things. When we have willpower and we make things happen, we do it with libido. Our consciousness has a certain degree of things that we can happen, that happen consciously, and we can even prevent automatic responses. For example, breathing.
We can decide to hold our breath up to the point where our body says, okay, no more, and continues breathing against our will. But there's a lot of libido happening in the background in the processes, but we have a small amount that we can use for certain things. And He says this libido, it always needs to express itself, the psychic energy, and it has to go specific places.
And very often that's a manifestation place. And he says when he had patients that were very creative, they had to create something. They had to paint, they had to write, they had to make music. And if they would not do it, they would get psychological problems because the libido was still in their system and it was not going where it was supposed to go.
So it was wreaking havoc in their psyche. They would get depressed, they would get bodily problems up till the point where they start to create again. It's similar to a cow which has an udder and it's just producing milk all the time.
And if you do not milk it, the udder will get bigger and bigger and it will be extremely painful for the cow, especially for modern cows who are, uh, let's say bred to have this very high throughput of milk. But this is what meant it needs to go into a specific form. It has to manifest itself through the things that you do.
He says many of the psychological problems that are happening is because people do not the things that they were intended to do. For example, there are certain life tasks that people should move toward. He says this was very clear in psychoanalysis, getting people out of the basement of their parents.
That they should establish a relationship with a partner of the other sex, then also establish themselves in society and all these things. And if they would not do it, this libido would flow backwards, regress, activate their childhood memories, or just acting up in the system, create problems. So the trick is to find out where the libido should actually go.
And The reason for Jung why these things, as I said, need to go into the body or even the environment has to do with people have to contend with it, as I mentioned it.
So people believe things rather when they're happening physically around them than when they're happening psychologically in the background, because then people also point it out like, oh yeah. I've always stomach problems. You always trip and have accidents. You always misspeak. So something is up.
And so far as I talked about in the beginning, when Jung uses the example of the body, this is something that people can understand, but with the psyche, it's more difficult. And he says things have to manifest so that you can actually interact with them. This is why he says the shadow or anima, these very abstract concepts.
Which are just manifestations of deeper psychological processes, has to do with the fact that you need to be able to interact with them. Otherwise it's foreign. It's very strange. It's not graspable.
He noted that when his patients have problems, he would very often let them draw, which has nothing to do with the artistic inclination of the patients, but rather with the fact that they need to put the libido somewhere. They have to manifest it in some kind of external thing. And when they would draw it, it doesn't matter the quality, just the drawing part of manifesting it.
This already created order in the psyche. And this was a kind of relief because it came outside. This is why he also very often called secrets a very big problem, because then it's bottled up inside of you. Very often things that should not be bottled up, but rather things that should be communicated with other people or clarified with other people.
And this is why the bodily is a necessary stage of psychological development. Like you cannot develop your psyche just with yourself alone in your head, in your apartment, in living room, but it has to be with other people and it has to be with the bodily and with the all earthly. And how would the psyche represent that?
Because the psyche represents kind of everything. Especially in dreams, fantasies, manifestations, visions, hallucinations. And that would be, as that shows the picture of this event, the earth. So everything related to the earth in a dream, for example, very often has to do with the body. Also snakes, because snakes live in the ground, then come out.
This is then a reminder to use analogies, not only Jung used analogies, but he said the whole psyche is set up like this, use analogies very often of the distant parts of the collective unconscious to remind people of certain things and make them aware of something.
And for Jung, this was such a big thing, this contending with the body, that he chose the word shadow for that, for this dark part you need to interact with, because very often your consciousness, you're the intellect, you're the mind. So the body is the other part and it's the other. So he said the shadow is the part that's always on the ground.
It's always in contact with there and this slightly invisible part, but that's always with you. So this was one of the reasons why I used shadow as a term to describe this dark part, not only because it's dark, but also because it's always close to the ground. So what does it mean in a broader context of humanity and how humanity developed?
Because interestingly enough, in the beginning of psychological development of humanity, he said, looking at hunter-gatherer societies or pre-scientific societies, superstitious societies, what he called primitive societies. Also, you see that like the seat of consciousness for them is very often not the head.
And it's, it's so cool. You know the word schizophrenia? I mentioned it before, a severe psychological condition. It comes from schizo and phrenia, which are Greek terms. Schizo means split and phrenia means the diaphragm, what you have under your lungs that are the reason why you can breathe because this muscle is moving.
And this is because the seat of the mind for the Greeks was there. It was way down lower. And he noticed that when he talked, for example, in people in Africa or South America, that they would point rather to the stomach or to the heart when they said, talk about the mind and where consciousness sits.
And the reason for that is very easy and convincing because you feel stuff there. You feel stuff, emotions in your stomach, and you feel them in your heart, which is immediate feedback. Like, I'm afraid, so I have a bad feeling in my stomach, right? I'm nervous, so my heart is racing.
So it makes sense to have the connection to that to say, ah, the differentiation between mind and body is not really there. This is a pretty modern and new thing, but rather it's like, oh, the feedback coming from there. So this has to be where the seat is of those experiences.
And this is how humanity started out, but things moved up and up and up, up and up to the head where we basically feel nothing. Like even the The brain doesn't have pain receptors. This is why you can have brain surgery while being awake because you don't feel it. So I guess it hurts when you put up the skull, but otherwise, like, there's no feeling in the brain.
Headaches, another topic, but some quotes. The scorners or despisers of the body would be the late Christian point of view, according to which one must despise the body because it's awkward and always teaches a different truth on what is the spirit. The body must be repressed or controlled, pressed into certain forms, and one must not listen to its teachings.
Therefore, the persecution of the body in the church, the glorification of the spirit through the modification of the body. And this is seen from a Christian point of view. Christianity is very spiritual. It discounts completely the bodily, earthly existence, material possessions. And so on.
And again, being kind of one-sided, but a necessary developmental step to say, okay, focus on one thing and then focus on the next thing. And interestingly enough, you have it of course also in Eastern religions. They say, oh, everything is an illusion. The body is an illusion in Eastern spirituality.
And the problem of the body, the consequence following is it's not even part of the immediate psyche of consciousness makes it so difficult to experience through basically our psyche and psychological apparatus. Another quote: Being in the body, you're caught. Therefore, the body is such an awkward thing. It's a definitive nuisance.
All people who claim to be spiritual, to get away from the fact of the body. They want to destroy it in order to be something imaginary. But they will never be that because the body denies them. The body says otherwise. They think they can live without sex or feeding, without ordinary human conditions. This is a mistake, a lie. The body denies their convictions.
And a new religion is always apt to disregard the body. Protestantism is more dangerous than Catholicism, which is older and takes the body into account.
And this is so interesting when you think about it in the modern context, because this was a huge topic years ago in Silicon Valley about like singularity, that you upload your mind into a computer and then you live forever.
This getting away from the body, the awkwardness and the strangeness of the body and the experience of the body to put it somewhere else is such an interesting thing. Happen to, to pop up again, especially as many of these things Jung talked about 100 years ago, but he's talking about basic psychological, like, conditions and functions.
So of course they will pop up again and again and again. It's just the phenomena that will repeat itself like an archetype and come up and again, especially as today we have a lot of control over the body. We can change really a lot of things because we understand it way better.
So for example, this topic of transgender that came up in the recent years to say like, oh yeah, this is not actually my body. My body is different. Like my mind is different from my body and let's change it through surgical means and medication and so on. This is all possible to make it look or feel like that.
The thing that I want from my, from my brain, from my let's say, conscious understanding how the world should be and how I should experience it. It's just an interesting thing to have it then popping up again that people try to escape their body because it's easier just to think in like psychological conscious realms.
But he said it's already a huge step up in the development of human beings and of culture. Especially Western culture, to rediscover the body. And when I read that, I, yeah, it really brought me to thinking. And I will, I will read it to you.
Nowadays we begin to admire the body again, and we are no longer afraid of admiring the beauty of the high mountains and the sea, or the beauty of the woods and the springs in the valleys. We even think we find God in nature. We go to Uetliberg and to see the sunrise. Unfortunately, the swing is too far to the other side. People are fanatical.
There's now the cult of nudity, what one calls in Germany Nacktkultur. And this is really funny because I'm from Germany and it's true, like especially in the eastern part of Germany, you have this FKK, which is this free body culture where people are just naked at the beach, especially. And so I have some, some lakes close to me and every summer that the naked people are there.
And since for centuries and also millennia where the body got less and less important through Christian spirituality, people are now rediscovering it. And we really see that in just a lot of aspects. Like if you look into the internet, like everything is incredibly bodily. People go to the gym, people show their bodies, people take supplements or hormones and everything.
So it's extremely focused on the body now. This, what was not so prevalent in the past and which was kind of missing, he said, as a developmental step in, in culture and human understanding of, of human experience. And the more you think about like how important the body is today and Lucky, 100 or 150 years ago, nobody thought about it that way.
It's exactly something you have, something that gets sick. But at the same time, this is where we have a lot of control just over it now because of our understanding. And I have to say, just as a conclusion to the things that Jung talked about when he talked about the body, while he talked a lot about the body. He did not give any advice for it.
So his therapy practice at the same time was always psychological, purely talking cure, talking with people, let them do things. He said that was very important that they actually do things.
But let's say what we say today when somebody is depressed to saying, okay, do sports regularly, go outside, experience nature, all these things where we know that they work because Of course, the body can, or things happening in the body can have a negative influence on the psyche. He never gave those advices.
So he's stating and hypothesizing, but at the same time, not really giving an advice, or at least not writing it down. But at the same time, we have to think it's 100 years ago. People were more in nature. People were more connected to the things that are happening around them. So this level of abstraction that we have today.
That you, for example, take supplement did not exist back then. You had to eat the real thing and the real thing very high likely came around you and you even planted and grew it or killed it.
So I would be very interested to, to know what you would think about our, at the same way, more bodily conscious approach, but at the same time, even more removed and abstract view of the body that we have today. Yeah, but this would conclude my presentation part and all the things that I could find about the body.
And I want to thank you for your attention, and I hope you learned something and had fun. And yeah, this would conclude the presentation part. Thanks.